Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David, P.
Here's an idea from a
viewer's boyfriend. I believe
our masks making people behave in crazy ways.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. So my boyfriend pointed
out to me when we went to the grocery store that
everybody's acting a little bit more crazy and on
edge, and maybe that things will go back to normal
as far as people behaving normally when the mask
mandates get lifted. And I'm from El Paso, Texas,
and I told him, I feel like everybody went into
like this mentality where they did get jailed
for not in a jail per say. But they did go into
kind of like house arrest and we were all.
Speaker 1: They felt like they were in jail
by having to wear a mask
Speaker 5: in the house.
I mean, I just wanted to get your thoughts on
that. As far as I feel like the masks have nothing
to do with the way people are behaving now.
Speaker 1: I don't know that it's the mask
specifically, but I do think that to some degree,
the long period were sort of like the rules
of engagement around being around. People were
changed and masks were part of it changed a lot
of people. Some people just from being home kind
of like forgot how to socialize. Normally, some
people are just really angry people and they're
lashing out. Some people are experiencing, you
know, sort of like a personal emotional crisis,
mental health crisis. So I don't think it's masks
per say that are making people act in crazy ways,
although some of the people are acting out saying
we shouldn't have to wear masks and that sense,
it's like the the fact that someone wants them
to wear a mask that's bothering them. But I think
it's a much bigger picture thing that hopefully
hopefully will start to settle as we hopefully
get out of this pandemic. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. Sign up at Join Packman
Unidentified: Gqom to get instant access to.